[تصفيق]
اردوغان رئيسا لولايه ثالثه ومنافسه يؤكد
انه سيواصل الكفاح من اجل الديمقراطيه
بايدن يقولون اتفاق النهائيا بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين لرفع سقف الدين
بات جاهزا ويحض على تمريره
غره جويه اسرائيليه تستهدف محيطه دمشق
وسوريا تقول ان الخسائر اقتصرت على
الماديه
[موسيقى]
انا بكون مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اعلن
رئيس هيئه الانتخابات التركيه احمد ينار
فوز الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بجوله الاعاده
في انتخابات الرئاسه وقال نار في مؤتمر
الصحفي ان اردوغان حصل على
52.14% مقابل 47.86
ذهبت لمنافسه كمال كليتشار اوغلو بعد فرز
اكثر من
99% من الاسواق
اعزائي الاعلاميين تم فتح اكثر من 99% من
صناديق الانتخابات داخل تركيا اما
الصناديق الخارج فان نسبه وصلت حتى الان
الى 88 بالمئه ارضوان حصل على 59 بالمئه
والصيد
حصل على اربعين بالمئه اما معدل الخارج
والداخل معا فالى الان وصلت نسبه الفرز
الى
99.43% السيد ارضوان حصل على
52.14 اما السيد كليتش فقد حصل على
47.80% اعتبارا من الان هناك مليونان
و250 الف صوت فارق بين المرشحين وقد تبقى
0.1% من الاصوات وهذه النسبه لن تغير
النتائج ونتيجه لهذا التصويت فاذا السيد
دراجه باي باردون
اختير رئيسا
للجمهوريه التركيه
وفي اول خطاب له بعد اعلانه رئيسا لتركيا
قال رجب طيب اردوغان انه سيفعل ما يجعله
يليق بثقه نخبيه كما كانت على مدار
العقدين الماضيين
اشكر كل الاعمال التي بذلها شعبنا وكلفنا
بحمل هذه المسؤوليه لاداره البلاد لمده
خمس سنوات مقبله اشكر شعبنا اذ اناط بنا
هذه المسؤوليه العظيمه ان شاء الله سنفعل
ما يجعلنا نليق بثقتكم وكما كنا جديرين
بثقتكم على مدار الواحد والعشرين عاما
الماضيه ماذا قلت لكم قبلا هذا الحب لا
ينتهي ليس الى يوم الاحد بل الى القبر
والممات
انتخابات الرئاسيه ليس انا بل الفائز هو
تركيا والمنتصر هو الشعب نفسه بجميع
اطيافه والفائز هو الديمقراطيه
في المقابل قال مرشح المعارضه التركيه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كمال كليتشار اولو ان
منافسه استفاد من كافه امكانات الدوله
واضاف اوغلو في خطاب له اضاف بان
الانتخابات كانت اكثر انتخابات غير عادله
في السنوات الاخيره وشدد مرشح المعارضه
على انه سيواصل الكفاح داعيا مناصره الى
مواصله النضال من اجل الديمقراطيه واعرب
كليتشار اوغلو عن حزنه العميق تجاه
الصعوبات التي تنتظر تركيا على حد تعبيره
الامه اظهرت رغبتها في تغيير النظام
الاستبدادي رغم كل الضغوط التي تعرضنا لها
حزب الشعب الجمهوري سيواصل النضال على كل
الجبهات وسنكون الرواد لهذا النضال ومهما
قدمنا لهذه الدوله فلن يكون هذا كافيا
لكنني اشعر بالحزن بسبب ما ينتظر امتنا من
صعوبات لكننا سنواجهها وادعو 25 مليون
تركي ممن صوتوا لي ان يواصلوا نضالهم
من جهتها هنا الزعيمه الحزب حزب الخير من
على الاكشنار رجب اردوغان بعد فوزه بولايه
رئاسيه ثالثه واكدت ان نتائج اظهرت انه
يجب على اردوغان تعلم درس كبير وان يكون
رئيسا لكل الاتراك كما عبرت عن خيبه املها
بخطاب اردوغان في اسطنبول والذي انتقد فيه
مرشح المعارضه التركيه كمال كليتشار اوغلو
[موسيقى]
علنا رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن التوصل الى
اتفاقه بشان سقف الدين العام بعد محادثات
مع رئيس مجلس النواب كذا مكارثي وخلال
كلمه له حطب هذا الكونغرس على تمرير
الاتفاق
لدينا اخبار ساره تحدثت مع رئيس مجلس
النواب مكارثي وتوصلنا الى اتفاق بشان سقف
الدين العام والان مستعدون لتقديم الى
الكونغرس وانا اعتقد انه من المهم ان نمضي
قدما
بعد اسابيع من المفاوضات الصعبه توصل
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب والبيت الابيض
الى اتفاق مبدئي لرفع سقف الدين بعدما قدم
الطرفان تنازلات رئيس مجلس النواب كبن
مكارتي قال ان الشعب الامريكي يستحق
الاتفاق المبدئي واضاف ان 95% من
الجمهوريين في المجلس متحمسون له
اعتقد ان هذه الاتفاقيه تؤطر كل ذلك من
الحد والمدخرات والنمو وهي لا تعطي الجميع
كل ما يريده لكن هذا هو الحال في حكومه
منقسمه البيت الابيض من جهته رحب بالاتفاق
ووصفه بانه خطوه مهمه الى الامام واعتبره
توافقيا ما يعني عدم حصول الجميع على ما
يريدونه لكنه اضاف انه يحافظ على اهم
اولويات الديمقراطيين
لقد قدم الرئيس بايدن نتيجه تتجنب تعثرا
كارثيا يمنعنا من الانهيار الاقتصادي
ويوقف الجمهوريين المتطرفين من الماجا من
التسبب في ركود يؤدي الى قتل الوظائف وهو
ما رايناه خلال الاسبوع او الاسبوعين
الماضيين بعض ما جاء في الاتفاق رفع سقف
الدين لمده عامين وتقليص الانفاق خلال
الفتره نفسها الابقاء على مستوى الانفاق
غير الدفاعي عند مستوى العام الحالي لعام
اخر
استرداد الاموال التي خصصت لمكافحه جائحه
كورونا
ولم تستخدم تجديد شروط العمل للحصول على
الدعم الحكومي تخفيض تمويل دائره
الايرادات الداخليه عدم فرض ضرائب جديده
التحدي امام بايدن ومبكرت الان هو اقناع
اعضاء في حزبيهما في الكونجرس بالتصويت
على المشروع حيث يعترض مشرعون جمهوريون
يمينيون وديمقراطيون يساريون على ما
يعتبرونه تنازلات في الاتفاق يتوقع ان
يصوت مجلس النواب على مشروع القانون
الاربعاء القادم قبل ان يتجه الى مجلس
الشيوخ لكن قد يتم ارجاء ذلك اذا واجه
معارضه قويه من الحسبين حسين الطاو
العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
افاد التلفزيون السوري بتصدي دفاعات
الجويه للضربات الاسرائيليه في سماء
العاصمه دمشق ومحيطها واوضح التلفزيون
السوري بانه تم تفعيل الدفاعات الجويه
بمجرد محاوله اجسام المعاديه اختراق
الاجواء السوريه من جهتها تحدثت وكاله سنه
للانباء عن خسائر ماديه فقط
[موسيقى]
ما عندي لا اشتباكات حدوديه بين افغانستان
وايران بشان الحقوق المائيه لنهره المند
صعدت حركه البم لهجتها مع طهران محذره من
انها قادره على احتلال ايران خلال 24 ساعه
اذا عزمت على ذلك
يتراشقان الاتهامات كما الرصاص على
حدودهما المشتركه الممتده على اكثر من 900
كيلو متر تجمع بين ايران وافغانستان
دولتان فرقتهما الانهار التي جرت فيهما
على قدر ما وصلت بينهما منذ مئات السنين
مياه اشعلت صراعا كان خفيا منذ عام
1982 لكن الخلاف على تقاسم مياه نهر هلمند
بات جليا
تعلو اصوات المدافع ومعها تؤكد ايران ان
الحدود تحت سيطرتها الكامله لكن لغط انجرى
مع طالبان ادى الى تلك الحوادث وفي كل
الاحوال اكدت طهران ان نزاعها مع كابول لن
يمثل سوى خساره استراتيجيه لكلتيهما
وبينما تحذر حركه طالبان مما اسمته
اصطناعه اعذار لشن حرب اشهرت اسلحتها
ودباباتها لينتهي بها الامر بتصعيد لهجه
احد قيادييها الذي قال انه اذا لزم الامر
بامكان طالبان الاستيلاء على ايران في
غضون 24 ساعه
هل من ذاك النهر الذي ينبع من جباله
هندوكوش شمال شرقي افغانستان ويصب في
بحيره هامون الايرانيه يعد اهم مصدر للماء
في البلدين وشريانا اساسيا لمحافظه سيستان
وبروجستان الا ان طالبان اغلقت سد كاجكي
ورفضت منحه طهران حصتها السنويه المقدره ب
820 مليون متر مكعب
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
في اسبانيا الحزب الشعبي اليمني يحقق
مكاسب كبيره في الانتخابات المحليه
والاقليميه
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت اوكرانيا تدميرها
اربعين هدفا في سماء كييف خلال هجوم
الروسين عليها
بالمسيرات وصواريخ كروز وقد شهدت العاصمه
الاوكرانيه ليله الماضيه عده انفجارات
وكانت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه افادت
باسقاطه 58 مشيره مفخخه اطلقت روسيا
باتجاه كييف
تتواصل في جده محاولات تمديد هدنه السودان
قبل انتهائها المقرر اليوم وقد اكد بيان
سعودي امريكي وجود انتهاكات من قبل اطراف
السودانيه اعاقت بشكل كبير ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه واوضح البيان ان الطرفي الصراع
استخدام طائرات عسكريه ومسيرات ما ادى الى
مقتل شخصين كما تم احتلال منازل المدنيين
وشركات الخاصه والمباني العامه بحسب
البيان الذي اكد وجود قناصه لقوات الدعم
السريع في الاراضي القريبه من المستشفيات
في مستولت عناصر تابعه للجيش السوداني على
امدادات طبيه في منشاتين ودعا البيان طرفي
الصراع بالسودان لتمديد الهدنه رغمى عدم
التقيد الكامل بها
في الاثناء نشر حزب الامه القومي السوداني
بيانا دعافيه طرفين نزاع في البلاد الى
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار الحزب حذر من ان
تسليح المواطنين بحجه حمايه انفسهم منعا
لتوسيع دائره الحرب كما طلب كلا من الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع طلبهما بوقف
الحرب العبثيه على حد وصفه والمضي قدما في
عمليه سياسيه للتحول المدني
في السودان ايضا دافع حاكم اقليم دارفور
منيوي في تصريحات العربيه دافع عن قراره
بالسمح للمواطنين بحمل السلاح مؤكدا انه
يهدف للدفاع عن النفس حيث اكد مناوي بان
اقليم دارفور يعاني منها شاشه امنيه
تضاعفت مع غياب تام للحكومه ادى الى
انتشار عمليات النهب والسرقه وقال ناوي ان
دعوته لحمل السلاح هي للدفاع عن النفس
وتقليل الخروق الامنيه بعد الحرائق في
المدن الرئيسيه مثل الجنينه وانيالا وشدد
المئويه على ان الوضع ينذر بالخطر خاصه
وان القوات الموجوده في دارفور قليله
وامكاناتها محدوده
تم حرق المواطنين وممتلكاتهم
وتم ويتم النهب للمواطنين امامهم
للشوحه الامكانيات
لذلك دعوتنا جاءت للتقليل مثل هذه الافعال
وبالتاكيد دفاع عن النفس مهم جدا واذا تم
تصليح المواطنين وخاصه في المدن وفي
الارياف
سيقلل من مساحه الاحتراق
نضافها حكم دارفور في تصريحاته العربيه
بان الحكومه غائبه بشكل تام منذ بدء الحرب
مشيرا الى ان وسطات وقف اطلاق النار لم
تنجح في وقف الانف
دعينا البسطاء في نشر امكانياتهم لمراقبه
الاوضاع
ولمراقبه الاوضاع اللي بتتعلق بوقف اطلاق
النار في الدارفور الا انهم لم يهتموا
بذلك في دارفور بل اهتموا فقط في الخرطوم
والدرفور ليس اقل شانا من الخرطوم
اعزز حزب الرئيس الموريتاني محمد ولد
الشيخ الالزواني غالبيته في الجمعيه
الوطنيه بحظه
107 مقاعد من اصل مئه وسته وسبعين مقعدا
قبل عام في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وفاز حزب
الانصاف الحاكم الذي كان له ثلاثه وتسعون
نائبا في البرلمان المنتهيه ولايته ب 80
مقعدا خلال الدوره الاولى للانتخابات في
الثالث عشر مما الجاري وسبعه وعشرين مقعدا
اخر من اصل 36 مقعدا انجرى التنافس عليها
في الدوره الثانيه
قال زعيم المعارضه في اسبانيا الى بلاده
دخلت حقبه سياسيه جديده بعد ان حقق حزبه
الشعب اليمين مكاسب كبيره في الانتخابات
المحليه والاقليميه الرئيسيه وصوت الاسبان
الاحد في انتخابات بلديه ومحليه تعد
بمثابه اختبار وطني لرئيس الوزراء
الاشتراكي بترو قبل سته اشهر من
الانتخابات العامه
[موسيقى]
معضله تحير كتابا اوكرانيين وروس بعد ان
دعت الجمعيه المدافع عن حريه التعبير
كتابا من كلا البلدين المتنازعين للمشاركه
في ذات الحدث
هل يمكن التحاور في زمن الحرب سؤال اثار
جدلا في اخر مهرجان للادب العالمي الذي
شارك فيه كتاب وادباء من كلا البلدين
المتصارعين ولكن تاثير الحرب قد يصل الى
الادباء حتى وان كان بعضهم منشقين عن
بلادهم
فالكتاب الاوكرانيون احتجوا على وجود كتاب
روس في هذا المهرجان الادبي واعتبروا
وجودهم بجانبهم قد يبدو بمثابه خيانه
للوطن ادرك ان هؤلاء الاشخاص لا يدعمون
حكومه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لكن
لدي واجبات كجندي
خلاف ليس بجديد
فقد وقع خلاف مماثل في مهرجان ادبي اخر
حين رفض شاعران اوكرانيا المشاركه فيه بعد
ان دعيت اليه كاتبه روسيه شهيره
[موسيقى]
919 انهت اول رحله تجاريه لها انطلقت من
شانغهاي وصولا الى بكين في اقل من ساعتين
كان على متنها 130 راكبا
المميز في هذه الرحله هو ان الطائره
الصينيه الصنع شركه كوماك هي راس الحربه
في مجهودات الصين لمنافسه
حيث انطلق المشروع في منتصف 2011 سي 919
ليست صينيه خالصه
فعدد من مكوناتها المهمه صنعت في الغرب
الطائره مجهزه بمحركين من نوع الليب ونسي
من صنع شركه امريكيه فرنسيه
الطائرات مكونه من مقصورتين من الدرجه
الاولى والسياحيه
بمجموع 164 مقعدا نطاقها العملياتي يصل
الى خمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه وخمسين كيلو
مترا تعتبر منافسه مباشره لايرباص 320
وبوعين 737
[موسيقى]
يواصل البرنامج السعودي لاعاده اعمار
اليمن دعم قطع التعليم في عدد من
المحافظات اليمنيه حيث قام بانشاء وتجهيز
مرافق في كليه الحقوق والصيدله بعدن اضافه
الى انشاء مدارس نموذجيه في عدد من
المحافظات اليمنيه
وهنا يتم
في كليه الحقوق بجامعه عدن
باجهزه ومعدات متطوره وتحضير معامل
تعليميه لتدريب الطواقم الامنيه في مجالات
تحقيق الجنائي والطب الشرعي وهو جزء من
مشروع البرنامج السعودي لتطوير وتاهيل
كليات جامعه عدن اتوفقنا مع البرنامج
السعودي الذي نقدم له الجزيره الشكر
والتقدير والعرفان لتوفير لنا مختبر جنائي
على مستوى عالي لم نكن نحلم
بمختبر كهذا
وهذا المختبر
يقسم الى ثلاثه المختبر الاساسي وهو
المختبر العملي المختبر الجنائي الذي
ستستفيد منه كل الجهات ليس فقط كليه حقوق
كليه حقوق ستؤهل الكوادر في المختبر
الجنائي سواء كانت لكليه الحقوق او في
الاجهزه الامنيه
وهول انتهى تجهيز فروع مختبرات كليات الطب
والصيدله
باجهزه حديثه في مجال تصنيع الادويه
ومعامل متخصصه للابحاث بالاضافه لتحضير
المراكز الاداريه ومراكز الهيئه التعليميه
المشروع التجهيزات مباني كليه الصيدله
والحقوق
هو مشروع ممول من قبل البرنامج السعودي
لتنميه اعمار اليمن
تكلفته حوالي سته مليون دولار تم تجهيزه
بحدث التجهيزات والتقنيات الحديثه
المستفاد منه اول مره كشريحه او الطلاب
طلاب البكالوريوس وايضا الطلاب الدراسات
العليا الماجستير والدكتوراه وايضا سوف
تستفيد منه
بقيه المرافق اللي هي مرتبطه بالعمل
الدوائي والصيدلانيه
وفي عدد من
المحرجه اكثر من 22 مدرسه نموذجيه في
محافظه المهره وسقطرى وتعز وعدن ولا حي
كما يواصل البرنامج تجهيز مدينه الملك
سلمان التعليميه والطبيه في المهره كاكبر
مشروع تعليمي في المحافظه
احنا هنا في الجامعه نشكر حكومه خادم
الحرمين الشريفيه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عادل امين الامير محمد بن
سلمان رئيس مجلس الوزراء حفظه الله ورعاهم
على الدعم المقدم من قبل الحكومه بشكل عام
للشعب اليمني ومنها نحن في جامعه عدن هذا
الدعم على سبيل المثال هذا المشروع اكثر
من 6 مليون دولار
تبرز هذه التجهيزات جزءا من جهود البرنامج
السعودي لاعاده اعمار اليمن والذي يركز
على النهوض بقطاع التعليم وهو ما يظهر
الجليا في كليات جامعه عدن التي يجري
تطويرها واحده بعد اخرى
ردفان دبيس العربيه عدن
[موسيقى]
قتل ثلاثه 33 مسلحا في ولايه مانيبور
الهنديه الواقعه شمال شرقي البلاد على يد
القوات الامنيه وكانت موجه الانف بدات في
الثالث من مايو الجاري على خلفيه خلافات
عرقيه مسؤول الولايه اعلن عن عمليات
التمشيط شامله بالاضافه لتسيير مروحيات
لمعرفه المهاجمين على المدنيين
في نهايه مشاهده تذكيرهم بابرزه عناوينها
اردوغان رئيسا لولايه ثالثه ومنافسه يؤكد
انه سيواصل الكفاح من اجل الديمقراطيه
بايدن يقول ان اتفاق النهائيا بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين لرفع سقف الدين
بات جاهزا ويحض على تمريره
وغارات الجويه اسرائيليه تستهدف محيط دمشق
وسوريا تقول ان الخسائر اقتصرت على
الماديه
نشره انتهت شكرا لكم اعطيني المتابعه والى
اللقاء عند المنتصف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات